But it's also,
they're documenting some of the greatest
standup specials in the history of
stand up. There's like the Chappelle
specials, the two recent ones that he did.
They're putting that stuff
out there and they're,
they're doing it in a way where
no one else would do it. Like Hbo,
which was the gold standard
for the longest time. Yeah.
They would never do two Dave
Chappelle specials at the same time.
Netflix is like, okay, we'll do Dave's
like, I got this new shit I want to do.
I'm going to do it in the belly
room at the comedy store. You know,
and Dave was so ridiculous about it.
Dave and I were downstairs. Yeah.
While he was doing this, while he was
filming this, we're downstairs, uh,
in the smoking area of the comedy
store getting high as fuck. Yeah.
And uh, he was so casual about it is
like, hey man, you want to do a set?
You did a set on the, no, no, no. I
just want to watch. I said, no, no.
I did three sets a night.
I go,
I'm just going to chill and hang
out in the back of the room,
but he was so relaxed,
like during his special being taped,
he's offering me a guest set. He's
like, hey man, I'll do a set, you know?
He still shows up. He'll fly to places
and show up and just do guests sets.
Yeah. I was in Denver. I
come out the green room,
it's Friday night and chapels in the green
room and I go there with it and goes,
hey Joe. I go, what are you doing? Oh
Man. It felt like coming to Denver. I go,
you want to do a set? It's like, oh yeah,
fuck it. So I bring him up on stage.
The audience is leaving, they're leaving.
Can I come back? It's your pals here.
They're like, what's, yeah, yeah.
Everybody comes back. He does 40 minutes.
It was amazing because that's
how he's doing it. He's like,
he's doing it for the art. He's not doing
it because he's making any money. Loves.
He did a free 40 minute show for these
people that came there to see me.
Fucking loves it and it's loves it.
And he's, it's like true with him, man.
He's a perfect example
of that just being true.
He'll show up Monday night at the comedy
store in front of 13 people and he'll
go on stage. I'll do a half an
hour in front of 13 people. Yep.
And he'll drink and smoke cigarettes
and we'll talk shit and laugh at his own
jokes. And everybody has like one of
the most magical experiences as a,
as an audience member you could ever have.
I was young comic in New York and there
was a place called the comedy village,
which was the Boston too. Sure.
So it became comedy village.
When did it become the village?
And it's done now,
but now it's like a Japanese restaurant,
a Japanese restaurant now.
Got It. Jamie cutten. No,
but, uh, there's a, um, uh,
and this is, I'm young like bark and
asking people to come in off the street.
Right. And, um, how old were
you when you started? A 23,
23. 23. Yeah. And, um,
and Chappelle comes in
and when he gets on stage,
there's probably 13 people in the crowd,
right.
And the fucking word gets out and you
just see people start slowly graphs like
goldfish.
You know what I mean?
When they could send some little
or ducks or something like that,
when they send some breads coming in
the pond and the place was packed within
like 20 minutes. Wow. Outside. It was
just everybody texting their friend.
Oh my God. Chappelle's here to do
so crazy. And he did six hours, Bro.
One
real dude. There were beer girls
like falling asleep or something.
Maybe four hours, 24
hours, something like that.
It, it, it's, it was jazz.
Right? It wasn't like,
it wasn't like I'm doing bits
and I'm murdering the whole time.
He has this ability to make the audience
comfortable intention so that it is not
anxiety inducing. Right. What,
what he can do is talk to you for five
minutes straight without a punchline.
As an audience member, you're
not going, oh my God is this guy,
is this guy not funny?
Well, that was when he was,
he was doing that for a while and
where he wasn't doing scheduled shows,
all he was doing was these
Poppins. And not only that, but he,
he brought a fucking speaker and set
up a microphone in the park in Seattle,
outdoor, outdoor. You
know, he did that early on.
Yeah, I was there. I watched it. We
watched him do it in Montauk, New York.
I saw him do it in Montreal.
We did a set together at club
soda and actually we got outside.
We went outside and Dave just said,
gather round. People gather it.
And he started doing stand up to people
in the street and they were like,
what in the fuck?
He was probably like 20.